con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a analizar la noticia económica de
hoy ya que el tipo de cambio del euro y
dólar por poco alcanzan la paridad
primera vez en 20 años al cierre los
expertos consideran que las recientes
subidas de los tipos de interés de la
reserva federal de eeuu han fortalecido
a la moneda estadounidense al dólar y
favorecido que los inversores entonces
se refugian en esta divisa al tiempo que
el riesgo de recesión en las
preocupaciones energéticas impulsadas
por la guerra de ucrania pesan cada vez
más sobre la eurozona estamos también en
nuestra mesa de trabajo con daniela
blandón daniela la saludo y bienvenida
nuevamente hola raúl pues sí bien
importante este tema sobre todo por lo
que implica también para la región
porque el dólar el dólar no solamente se
está fortaleciendo frente al euro sino
frente a muchas monedas latinoamericanas
y saludamos entonces a nuestro
habitables claudio loser él es el
presidente de la consultora centennial
américa latina' ex director para el
hemisferio occidental del fondo
monetario internacional el fm y claudio
gracias a nuevamente por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de francés 4
siempre es un placer estar con ustedes
bueno claudio hablemos entonces de esta
paridad del euro y el dólar que ya casi
que es un hecho esto qué implicaciones
tiene para la gente de a pie
la gente de a pie
digamos hay gente de a pie en europa y
hay gente de a pie en nuestra región la
gente a pie en europa bueno
el euro que había estado hace un año o
algo más a 115 en mayo a 105 dólares por
euro hoy está igual eso es justamente
por lo que estaba explicando y la suba
de las tasas de interés y el miedo que
existe en este momento es para los
distintos inversores de tener el dinero
en europa con todo este problema de
guerra y problema de
lo que es energía y pasarse a eeuu que
con todas sus fallas sigue siendo más
seguro para la gente de a pie en dólares
por supuesto esto quiere decir que en
europa es más barato y comprar cosas
europeas más barato o sea acá y siempre
uno por otro el ayuno gana
y américa latina
claro claudio pero yo le quería
preguntar digamos son casi 19 países si
no me equivoco los que conforman esta
eurozona que tienen que tienen el euro
contra solamente un país eeuu con el
dólar teniendo todo esto en cuenta el
miedo del mercado digamos por una
posible recesión la guerra en ucrania
como está afectando directamente a
europa pues podría digamos el dólar
pasar al euro esto es un escenario casi
que impensable
no es impensable para nosotros los más
viejos recordamos cuando el euro estaba
por abajo del dólar estaba creo que en
un momento llegó a 90 centavos una cosa
así estoy hablando de historia antigua
en este momento puede darse
acá todo va a depender directamente en
los próximos días si el banco central
europeo- la señora lagarde es la
presidenta de la gobernadora del banco
central sube las tasas de interés no
quieren subir la tasa de interés por
miedo a la recesión pero la caída del
euro puede crear más problemas porque
mucha gente que tiene ahorros en euros
se van a ir al dólar para esta situación
o sea que no es nada impensable en este
momento
el señor lo será ahora nos venimos para
américa latina porque level del dólar
también está fortalecido en esta región
sobre todo en algunos países como
argentina colombia o chile porque se da
esta situación y también hay factores
internos que las empujan el precio del
dólar
y la caída del euro y la caída de la
caída de los de los pesos colombianos
[Música]
los chilenos y los presos argentinos se
ven que tenemos la hermandad en eso caen
en parte por eso sin embargo en cada uno
de estos casos además está la situación
interna en argentina mi país de origen
es un problema de caos económico y
político que aunque que con un nuevo con
una nueva ministra un poco paro en chile
porque no se sabe qué va a pasar con la
nueva constitución si será aprobado o no
y por supuesto en colombia en donde más
donde más sorprendido de que he quedado
con esta subida a 4 mil 500 pesos por
dólar realmente es debido
la incertidumbre
referida al nuevo presidente pero a
pesar de haber nombrado a un economista
de mucho prestigio como es el señor
ocampo o sea que se combinan las dos
cosas es el miedo que está llevando a
que la gente se vaya de los presos a los
drones claudio y como esta situación
como le decía también el principio
afectaría digamos a todas las
importaciones el costo de vida es para
la ciudadanos que todavía vivimos en
nuestra región de américa latina y el
caribe cómo va a afectar cuánto se
estima también las proyecciones que
aumente la inflación digamos si lo
podemos poner todos los países una bolsa
como lo dijo usted es bien difícil
porque pues cada país tiene su
particularidad pero más o menos como se
podría proyectar una proteína ción en en
nuestra región
es un poco difícil
sin embargo la gente de a pie o de auto
pequeño como digo yo va a sufrir porque
una subida tan fuerte en el dólar
evidentemente afecta no solo los bienes
importados sino a aquellos que se
exportan
y eso evidentemente va a pegar es muy
difícil decir que osea colombia que
tenía una tasa de inflación es
relativamente baja parece que va a tener
una de las inflaciones más altas de los
últimos tiempos quizás del 15 por ciento
estoy hablando muy en general no todo el
número en cuenta perfectos en chile que
estaba en 3% no me sorprendería que con
el tipo de cambio a más de 900 pesos
esto genere también una inflación que
puede llegar al 10 por ciento en
argentina
y ahí tenemos de una dinámica diferente
a ella la inflación está la pregunta es
si va a estar en 60 o en 80% señora
hacer una respuesta de 10 segundos le
pido dicen que cuando el dólar sube
nunca más vuelve a bajar en los países y
eso muestra la tendencia va a volver a
bajar o no volverá a bajar
e
no puedo decir que el dólar nunca baja
ha bajado en colombia muchas veces ha
bajado en chile depende de las
circunstancias no hay tal cosa de que el
dólar queda platicado arriba para
siempre depende de las condiciones
internacionales pero más aún y ahí
terminó mucho más aún de la política
interna